hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible uh game that you just ended
from the World Chess Championship match
between the animal machine the dingler
and I have no idea how long this video
will last as uh the game is incredibly
uh complicated so for those of you who
are once again just here for the moves
there is a section below just show me
the moves you can check out the moves in
like one minute but for those of you who
want to check out the game uh you are in
the right place uh now uh nepo is
leading it's four to three this is only
uh game eight now so we are in the
second half of the match let's see what
happened here and why this is such an
incredible game uh it could also be game
six uh it's that incredible so I I truly
Envy those of you who are seeing it for
the first time now the first move was
made by this gentleman here it is the
director of The Mining and processing
plant uh Thailand uh who is a sponsor of
the feeder wheelchairs Championship
um there you have it making the first
move I think he made E4 but it was not
made in the game uh looks like a bond
villain a little bit but I don't know I
haven't seen all that many Bond movies
now getting to the game let's check it
out the ding once again opens with Pawn
to D4 uh we have Knight to F6 by Nepal
not we have Pawn to see for upon the E6
and now uh in game two we had the
antonyms that would Knight to F3 but
here we have Knights the C3 and ding now
says all right uh first half of the
match is over now we're playing serious
just uh let's bring our main weapons out
and the uh nipple goes for it Bishop to
B4 the nimso Indian defense is on the
board we have E3 biting castles and now
Ponte A3 something that was discussed at
length during the live broadcast
sort of uh a patent by Fabiano caruana
that really makes it difficult for black
to go for for usual setup as you'll see
here Bishop captures and C3 B captures a
standard way of ruining white spawn
structure but we've seen a lot of games
I remembered that I covered like in 2022
although this is not considered the best
now in in top chess it still produces
the most wins then not doubling your
pawns against the denimzo and uh I think
we've had a couple of very nice games I
I remember you're in farm Forest played
a really brilliant one and I can
remember who the other players were but
um you know it's a it's an attempt uh
you have to look for inequality in order
to win games so these six Here and Now
Knight to E2 and this is already taking
a very different approach than what you
would expect Bishop to D3 is what
players usually play here then you run
into something like E5 and uh black gets
a a lot for him uh out of his position
for example he captures the after
there's even Knight captures on e4 and
now if Knight to F3 you can even play
Rook d8 put pressure on white Here and
Now white will just Castle here and it's
uh you know it's a it's a nice position
uh for black so instead we have Knight
to E2 here by Ding and now Pawn to C5
this is the prime the principal way to
play against the double Pawn setup
against the Nim so uh here the pawns are
attacked you will play B6 attack the C4
Pawn via Bishop to A6 and then the
Knight will also help out with the
attack something like Knight to C6 to A5
going after C4 uh this is all a very
standard but we've seen in the games
that we've covered that you can uh black
will try to win this C Pawn the entire
game and in the end might eventually uh
even accomplish this but somehow black
loses the game so uh we've seen this
happen quite a lot now here Knight the
G3 biting and not Knight the C6 we have
Rook to A2 at the star move of the game
only one of the star moves of the game
uh the idea is to bring the Rook over to
D2 as you'll see later on in the game so
here Pawn to B6 we have Ponte E4 Dean
grabs the full Center and now Bishop to
A6 Nepal just going uh for principal
moves here he wants to go after the C4
Pawn uh Bishop to G5 by Ding and now
Pawn to H6 and here Ponte H4 already
offering a piece and while you could
capture it in in a few ways nepo decides
to capture it right away with h captors
and G4 now there's a lot to consider
here the the throwing in of the move C
captures on D4 is one of them and now
adjust the to give you an example if you
now capture the bishop and play G6
because you have to play this uh you
have to free the G7 Square for the king
to be able to play King to h8 you know
if the Knight moves just Queen H5 and
are gonna get the checkmated so G6 and
now uh there are a few few different
ways you could play this but let's say
you capture characters captures and now
you play something like Rook to D2 okay
uh the game continues it's nothing
spectacular but white could also play
Ponte F4 look at this absolute Madness
and now how do you continue if Knight's
the D7 then you go Queen to G4 again
trying to Checkmate black now King to G7
and now Pawn to F5 and now look at this
Rook to h8 uh Ponte F6 check what a
black will have to give up uh the piece
because otherwise he just gets
checkmated captures captures and
captures and now there's this Knight to
H5 check move forking the king and the
queen you have to capture with the Rook
so basically you're giving up the
exchange but now the D4 Pawn is hanging
and here we have Queen captures on D4
and we would have this very very uh
interesting position where uh well where
only black can be better and that's the
main difference between C counters and
D4 and accepting dings Bishop right away
uh never played H captains and G5 right
away and it is now as of move 12 that we
have a completely new game up until this
point there were a few games that led up
to this game but in the database there
is only one game and it's uh it's again
basically between two two thousand
players so nothing um of High Caliber uh
and uh here is where things get
incredibly interesting now there was a
lot of talk uh online uh um today about
how ding's preparation has leaked and
that the the work of him and his second
has leaked online I've seen the uh the
subreddit on this and there are even
some games where Rook the E8 was played
uh unleash chess it was um uh sort of a
thread where a certain account uh by the
name of of f vitelli played against
opqrstuv some 72 games for maybe 77
games and they've used this exact same
position and some other positions from
the Nepal versus being match before the
actual games in the world championship
match was played so it could be that
this is actually ding um versus a
rapport just training online uh I don't
know how how probable that is I mean
people are saying that that's true I
will discuss this a little bit more
after we check out the actual game so
here age captures on G5 this is what
nepo goes for he accepts the bishop with
h captures and now Pawn to G6 and here
adding uh kinda took his time here
because he has to decide between just
capturing and pawn to F4 and Ponte F4 is
very interesting here because now uh the
C Pawn is defending the D4 pawn and if
we try the same line here that we've
already tried let's say queen to G4 King
to G7 and not F5 now it's a little bit
different because after Rook to h8 and
F6 check you're gonna trade here
captures captures and captures but now
Knights the H5 check works because after
captures and captures there's no queen
or Knight cap or sun D4 and it's not uh
easy to continue this with black if you
want to play the absolute engine precise
move you have to go King to G8 then Rook
to F2 comes attacks the queen and I
don't know uh looks uh looks kind of odd
let's say uh Queen comes to G7 now this
is a thread you're gonna bring the Rook
back see capture Sandy for sea captors
Knight captures it's uh it's a really
weird position to say the least uh but
uh you you could go for this with this
Ponte for move idea now this is all
again all 0.00 uh so it's it's a dead
raw but not when humans play it
obviously uh but here ninjas play G
characters and F6 Queen characters and
F6 uh and now uh interestingly both of
them have now equal time an hour and 40
minutes on the clock and here we have
Ponte E5 and this is a crucial move in
many lines because it frees up the E4
Square for the White Knight new nipple
two can E5 and now ding played Pawn to
D5 and this is again very very tricky
the the crazy line to consider here is
Knight to the E4 because there's so much
here uh again I mean it it ends in the
draw but it's so spectacular Queen to F4
Bishop to D3 uh now you defend the
Knight and now Bishop captures in C4
because if Bishop captures then the
Knight hangs with check you chase away
the queen with G3 Queen F5 and now you
play this spectacular Pawn to F3 move
you've sacrificed a full Rook here and
after Bishop captures on A2 look at this
queen to D2 now attacks the bishop and
threatens Queen to H6 Queen to h8
Checkmate you have to play Queen
captures on F3 and after Queen H6 you
have to give up the queen captures
captures and now after King to G7 so you
can play Rook to h8 you play some like
Knight to G5 and uh it's uh I mean the
Knight is hanging Queen is coming to H7
luckily you can save this bishop to D5
but you have to find all of this queen
to H7 checking F6 now Queen H4
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries of course you can't capture
the Knight that would be just silly and
then Queen comes to H4 with a nice
Checkmate uh so here you would have to
play Queen to H4 now Rook day trade
attacks the queen Knight the H7 a
discovery from the queen king G7 and
queen to F6 check you force the
capturing of the Knight or rather you
can't capture because then it's
Checkmate captures and captures with
Checkmate you have to go King to G8 and
now Bishop captures on G6 this is um
I mean this is absolute Madness uh
captures captures with check sorry not
captures with check um
uh here a Ruble capture on H7 and now
you will play Bishop captures King
characters and queen characters and you
will now have this position uh where
white will
uh most likely uh for a force of
repetition here because black does have
enough compensation for the queen so
after the characters on E5 D5 was played
ding did not go for this Knight's day
four line but this is uh again also
incredibly complicated uh never played
Knights the E7 here you could also
capture let's say captors captures and
then what is happening the Knight is
saying and Bishop is hanging so you will
have to capture an F1 and after captures
captures play something like Knight's
day five with the ding
uh having his his beautiful pass deep on
the Knight is also coming to E4 I mean
it's um it's uh you know that probably
you can hold this but it just looks very
nice so instead nipple played Knight the
E7 and now ding played Pawn to D6 and
this is a this is a beautiful move to
play uh point is that you could uh throw
in a nice Rook to D2 or some other
Quinta A4 ideas but the D6 is just
beautiful by Ding and you'll see why
here the situation on the clock is a bit
different
uh ding is now down to 50 minutes and
nipple has an hour and 15 minutes on the
clock but here we have Knight to F5
Knights the E4 attacking the queen queen
back to d8 and now Queen to D3 uh you
want to play G4 but if you play G4 then
Bishop B7 uh could be an issue and then
Queen to D3 you have to defend so that's
why uh ding went with Queen to D3 right
away uh we have King to G7 you have to
make this move in order for King Rook
will be able to come to h8 and now we
have Pawn to G4 chasing away nepo's
Knight and here Bishop to B7 the only
move without this move you're just dead
uh and now Rook to H3 this is a
beautiful move by then you don't want to
capture the Knight because then he
captures and you have problems here
uh so Rook to H3 was played uh and now
we have Knights the H4 uh the Knight is
not protected but now uh ding instantly
played Pawn to G5 the reason why
sorry about that uh the reason why you
kind of have to play something here uh
is that uh how do you how do you play
this the real question is can you
capture an E4 and after Queen captures
Knight to D6 If you eliminate this past
the D pawn it seems like you're back in
the game but there's Queen captures on
E5 check and now you have to find F6 and
after Queen to H2 you have to find the
Knight to F7 uh Rook to H7 check King G8
and now how do you assess this how do
you even approach to assessing this
position
uh The Rook will come to D2 the bishop
will come to G2 uh seems like black
can't survive but it's uh I mean it's a
very ugly position to have so instead
after this Rook to H3 nipple played
Knights the H for Rook dh4 is also a
move to consider but um I mean this is
uh too too hard to even try to make
sense of uh so instead Knights the H4
was played and even nippo had to spend
his time here and now ding played Pawn
to G5 now he's threatening to pick up
the Knight and the problem is if Knight
goes back look at what ding had in mind
Ponte F4 freeing up The Rook um from 80
to come to H2 look at this beautiful
Rook of Rook day a A2 to H2 and now if
Rook to h8 now you just double up and
now for example Rook captures on H3 uh
Queen captures on H3 and now look at
this queen to h8 stopping trackmate but
now Queen captures Rook captures Rook
captures King captures and uh Pawn to D6
now just ends the game there's no way to
stop promotion
uh so that's the problem and probably
what nipple missed after Ponto G5 so
here at nipple played Bishop captures on
e4 we have Queen captures and now Knight
back to F5 and now feel free to pause
the video here and try to find a winning
idea for ding uh while I give you a
couple of seconds
foreign
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh incredible idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
worth the D2 this movie is so beautiful
that I refer to Rook 8 to D1 as the the
Anderson move due to his beautiful win
in the Evergreen game but this move uh
if it finishes for a win by ding I will
refer to this move as the ding for the
rest of time uh so why is this so
impressive the problem is if Queen
captures an E5 check F6 and G captures
now Queen captures You're Gonna Play
Queen to H2 okay you have a rook H7 but
then just Rook to h8 and now how do you
play this if Rook to D2 uh there's Rook
captures on H3 and now if Queen captures
or Bishop captures just Rook 838 and
this is now much much different uh than
what the ding found ding found this
beautiful Improvement Rook to D2 and now
with the d-pawn covered uh there's
really no good good move here for Nepal
the problem is if Queen captures on G5
then look at this again Queen captures
an E5 check and now of course Queen F6
loses The Rook H7 check losing the queen
and if F6 you will just play a nice
Queen to H2 and now after Rook dh8 is
pretty much the same idea captures
captures captures and after King
captures on h8 yes black has a queen but
D7 again you cannot stop promotion
so I have to root 32 Rook the a chain
was played by Nepal but this is um not
enough ding finds the uh the the best
move Rook captures on h8 Queen captures
and now it's time to win the game for
ding feel free to pause the video once
again and win it while I give you a
couple of seconds
uh so congratulations to everyone who
spotted it uh it's not an easy one Rook
to D3 so a second Rook lift is needed to
finish this masterpiece so Rook to eight
due to D2 to D3 this is uh absolutely
incredible unfortunately ding did not
find it the reason why it's so hard to
find is that after let's say Rook to d8
you will play Rook the H3 attack the
queen and once the queen moves you will
play Queen captures on E5 check and
after F6 G captures King F7 Rook to H7
trick King to E8 now you have to play
Rook to E8 with Rook D7 with check and
it's absolutely spectacular or even the
king doesn't have to go here the king
can also go to G8 but you still play
Rook to E7 that's the beauty of this uh
Knight of course cannot capture because
you will capture attack both the rook
and the queen so your only option is
Rook captures here but then look at this
for F7 check King to H7 and now Rook the
E8 attacks the queen uh wins the queen
or you uh get to Checkmate the once the
queen moves like the queen captures and
now Rook till h8 Checkmate only one of
the lines however ding played D7 first
and now it's still great but it's a bit
different because nepo now plays Rook 38
of course he stops the pawn queen
characters with check King to H7 and now
Queen to H2 with check here ding repeats
125 check King H7 and queen H2 checking
G7 and while some people thought okay
maybe ding will repeat a ding just
played Queen to C7 and this is the move
that keeps the attention keeps the game
alive and keeps dings winning chances
alive Queen the H4 by nepo this is the
the Jedi Mind streak moved that once I
saw I was like Wow and I thought that
they didn't would just win the game
because it's a free rook and d8 but
that's the problem when you watch the
game with an engine bar on the side once
you see the engine bar go up uh you know
that okay it's it's uh it's uh just a
blunder The Rook is absolutely free but
the ding did not capture the England
played King the D1 he trusted nepo on
this one uh it's like uh yeah it's a
general Mind Trick there's no other way
to put it the problem is it's uh
impossible to calculate and also
I think kind of trust that Nepal a bit
too much here because after a queen
capture San Diego look at this Queen T
for check it seems that you have a
Perpetual here but after rookie two
queen to B1 check King D2 Queen to B2
check King to D3 there's Queen B1 check
Rook C2 and now Queen captures on F1
with check and now you go Rook to a King
to D2 and now if Queen captures here you
will hide behind The Rook or another uh
fine line here after Rook the C2 check
uh you could also uh not uh after this
move and queen to D1 check you could
also not uh block with rookie could also
play uh King to E4 but now after Queen
captures and C2 check Bishop to D3 and
now uh the queen will just move in here
you're gonna get checkmate the queen of
six check uh even if some Knight to D6
check you can even harass the the white
king a little bit there's always this
check and the second Queen appears and
it looks like maybe you can Checkmate
the white king let's say 94 checking
goes a uh F4 E5 check even King here
Queen check King to G3 and now there are
no more checks and it's completely
winning for white so absolutely
incredible stuff here but nipple pulls
through Queen H4 confuses ding ding
plays King to D1 and now just Queen
captures and G5 The Rook is defended
there's no G Pawn uh ding no longer has
a way of winning this game but it's only
move 32 so both players can still make a
mistake King the C2 by ding we have
Queen to E7 and not Bishop to G2 uh and
here nipple if he can if he finds this
he can draw on the spot Knight the D4
check kinda draws on the spot because
after you take this uh there's Rook
captures on D7 the pawn is no longer
defended and I have to let the queen E5
check F6 Queen moves somewhere uh you're
gonna play Rook capture Sandy for and
after captors captures with the access
to the queen side this will be a draw
you have too many pawns for for that
Bishop man G2
so instead E5 was played by nepo and
this now allows Bishop D for now uh ding
again uh you know a catches a glimpse of
of maybe a win here because now Knight
to D4 check is impossible if you now try
this captures and captures and queen
captures on E5 check uh King to G8 or F6
doesn't really matter uh it's gonna be
uh a loss here because you're just gonna
have uh too too hard of a time playing
the C4 captures any seven Bishop will
move characters countress now it's much
different uh in that position you had
four pawns now you have two pawns on the
king side for for that Bishop so not not
even close so instead after Bishop D4
nipple goes Knight to H6 he wanna he
wants to bring the Knight to
uh G4 and go for the white king uh Queen
captures on A7 ding realizes that now
it's time to stop trying to Checkmate
the blacking and you have to play for
material Knight the G4 a situation on
the clock is 19 minutes for a ding and
16 minutes for Nepal so nepo actually
had less time than ding uh going into
this position uh and now Bishop to F3 a
move that will haunt the ding for a very
long time I believe uh because here
after Bishop to C6 uh ding still has
excellent winning chances the problem is
now after E4 you can play Queen captures
on B6 and if Knights the E5 you just
play Bishop to B5 uh everything is
protected the C4 Pawn is protected the
D7 Pawn is protected now you push the a
pawn and the ding will very likely win
this game however ding played the bishop
to F3 which also kind of works if the
Knight goes back but you know it's
nipple the Knight is not going back nepo
just plays Knight captures on F2 and
here he says take my knight I just I
just want to get rid get rid of this
d-pawn and then it's okay so Rook
characters and F2 you can be played and
it was played but you know it's very
hard for thing the problem is if you go
back with the bishop then the Knight
goes back and then okay you can capture
here and then E4 is coming E3 is coming
and so on and then you maybe give nipple
a bit too much counter play so Rook
captures on F2 was played and now we
have E4 first uh attacking the bishop
rookie two and now Pawn to F5 so nipple
is now down a piece but he's up a pawn
and uh well only up one Pawn but these
pawns are incredibly weak so
uh if you allow those pawns to start
marching forward it's not going to be
easy and here the situation is on the
clock uh five minutes for uh ding uh and
he needs to make one more move to reach
time control can he do it in five
minutes he let his uh clock run down to
four seconds and he made a move uh he
started shaking he started you know
going like this and he he made his move
and he played Queen characters on B6
because there was too much to to decide
whether to give up the bishop right now
and then after I've captors capture here
and then let's say queen captures on D7
going after Queen to D3 you play queen
king to B2 and the game continues or do
you wanna play Queen capture some B6 uh
and pretty much get things resolved
right away he played Queen captures on
B6 and now Nepal replied with Rook
captures on D7 and nip also took quite
some time here because he also kind of
like this the problem is here The Rook
G2 this is the move that Ding took five
minutes to find uh going after the G6
pawn and now even if Queen D3 check King
to B2 there is no continuation you have
to trade Queens here and once the Queens
get traded off you will play Bishop
captures on e4 and it's uh it's a draw
here equal material nothing spectacular
uh so Nepal played real characters on D7
uh he wanted to keep the chances alive
and now Queen to B8 uh we have Queen to
D6 again nipple took some 20 minutes
here uh but he wanted to make sure that
it actually works so here the queen
trade is forced you cannot allow Queen
the D1 with check uh dink captured an
apple traded back and now Bishop
captures an E4 you can't plug in those
pawns they're simply too strong so ding
has to give back the piece uh King to F6
uh didn't play Rook d8 and he was in
this position on a move 45 uh that nepo
ending agreed to a draw as there is
nothing more to be done here yes he is
up a pawn and okay it's a past napon but
his C pawns are double nip also has a
pass G pawn and there's no way
for you to actually uh for for you to
actually do this uh so really incredible
stuff ding again managed to to surprise
him win for this beautiful uh okay so we
could also make a quick summary for this
so a nice indian was played for those of
you who are just interested in the moves
uh the the C Pawn was was doubled didn't
play this weird Rook to A2 idea which
you know will be useful later on in
bringing the Rook to D2 or maybe maybe
even H2 uh here uh being offered the
p-snip accepted the bishop and now we
have this crazy position here where uh
Quinta D3 G4 and now Rook to H3 and now
look at this G5 captures captures and
now Rook the D2 spectacular move by Ding
and now nipple is without a move ding is
completely winning but the ding messes
up he plays Pawn to D7 Rook to d8 and
now Queen captures on E5 but this is not
enough to win the game uh he played
Queen to C7 and now nipple completely
bluffed him with Queen to H4 he offered
the full rook and if ding takes it it's
a win but ding didn't take it and in the
end the game basically resolved in uh in
a very quick drawn Apple was down a
piece but in the end the ding had to
give up the bishop for the pawns and
here they agreed to a draw so this is
basically the short version hope you
enjoyed that as well and now getting
back to this position uh where I said
that there are a couple of games in the
database that reached this exact same
position so here we've discussed some
moves after H4 was played we've
discussed C captures on D4 and a cat H
captures on G5 but the move that was
played in the sort of a secret account
of Ding and arihad Rapport was Rook the
E8 and here uh a pretty spectacular
victory was achieved by white I will put
a link to this leeches profile in the
description below first thing you will
see not first thing first thing okay
will be the the seven games played so
far but then will be the leeches link so
if you want to check out all those games
but basically this is the line that was
explored in that one particular session
and it was explored between two players
uh it was a rapid game between a 1500
player and a 2700 plus player so it's a
really really odd and they've explored
some other lines that were played in
This World Series championship match so
the lines that they've discussed here is
Rook to D2 Quinta E7 and now Ponte E5
and now if D captures an E5 Knights the
E4 black sacrifices a queen here and
after Bishop captures Knight captures on
D2 it seems like black has enough
compensation but there's this
spectacular Bishop to F6 move
and now uh after Knight captures an F1
Queen to G for threatening mate and
after d capture is not D captures an E5
and now I have to Rook a to d8 trying to
give up a rook here uh just Queen F4 and
the white uh is checkmating black and
now the problem is if for example King
to H7 uh there's Bishop to G5 and again
you cannot allow uh the The Rook to to
come alive Queen captures and F7 is
coming and if Rook the f8 then just H5
and this is a spectacular attack and it
it really I mean I don't know now it's
the king the G8 now Queen comes to F6
and you are again getting checkmated
either like this or you capture the
bishop and then a h Captain G6 a rook h8
will be Checkmate so uh it could be that
this is not doing an Rapport and that is
just too big of a coincidence but then
that then it's just a too big of a
coincidence and I mean they're really uh
you know it could be but I don't I don't
think so I really think uh that their
preparation leaked and now it's merely a
question of how early in the match did
it leak how early it's very I mean if
people on Reddit found it then of course
the nepos camp and Nepal's seconds also
found it and if ding was coming into
every game in this match uh with a with
a sort of a disadvantage that nepo knew
or at least partially knew what he was
going to play then that's um I mean
that's a pretty big issue and it was uh
I mean it also looks like something
pretty silly to be using uh I mean a
silly account like this that the train
for World Series Championship begins
because of course uh players will refer
the database for the moves that were
played and they will see who repeated
those moves like uh a month ago uh two
months ago three months ago four months
ago and I mean it's hard to say I'm very
interesting uh very interested see what
you guys think if you have any more
insight on this do share in the comment
section below so everyone else can
uh you know brush up on it as well uh
but yeah that's basically it uh the the
short version once I know more we're
probably going to discuss it in the next
video but it could be I have no idea if
this is the case um you know I'm just uh
saying what uh what information is
publicly known uh so yeah uh that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it uh a nice
draw uh ding almost took the win but
nipple holds his um holds his lead it
will now be four and a half to three and
a half and we'll see what happens
um in the game nine of the world cheers
championship match uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank Paul SAS lucasito uh Jose
Palacio Scott McCray and Max Sally for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
and thank all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the World Chess Championship Match until
it finishes uh so thank you I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day and sorry my voice haven't
recovered yet I'm I'm doing the best I
can see soon